la radio
[Musica]
la radio probabilmente tutti noi la
conosciamo
quel media che abbiamo sempre avuto con
noi quando siamo entrati in macchina a
casa in bagno ovunque ma la radio
probabilmente noi conosciamo la radio
legata alla musica la radio
ecco i media che ormai li compie
cent'anni e che oggi
[Musica]
sta subendo un grande attacco un attacco
che forse è giusto ma probabilmente se
apriamo un attimo lo sguardo a livello
mondiale
ci rendiamo conto di un dna di un
qualcosa che se questo media rimasto
così longevo se c'è un motivo
la radio
noi la conosciamo come il volume come il
cambio di stazione come un contenuto la
radio non è la musica e basta la radio
non può essere paragonata a spotify o
youtube
qua tic toc tutti i giorni mi sento dire
la radio sta morendo
beh penso che ci siano dei punti di
vista che noi dobbiamo e siamo obbligati
a prendere in considerazione la radio e
live la radio un contenuto local la
radio trasmette emozioni la radio non è
una playlist di spotify un podcast la
radio non è on demand la radio di oggi
la radio analogica di ieri e quella
radio che la possiamo spegnere che ci
può accompagnare è quella radio che ci
dà un contenuto e quel brand che ci dà
una festa che ci fa festa è un brand che
ci individua ma oggi la radio e mono
direzionale è uno di quei pochi media
che noi non possiamo mettere laiche non
possiamo condividere la radio oggi non
vi traccia non li ascolta
ultimamente sono usciti alexa sono
usciti numerosi dispositivo oltre al
telefono che avete in mano e spesso si
sente dire che vi ascolta la radio non
vi ascolta questa è la differenza
poi vorrei raccontare perché sono così
legato alla radio e ci sono nato dentro
per colpa di mio padre
io vorrei raccontarvi una missione
umanitaria che ho affrontato qualche
anno fa in kenya a circa 70 chilometri
da nairobi in un piccolo villaggio di
circa 2.500 persone che mandava messaggi
alla comunità di radio maria in italia
tramite un missionario
purtroppo questo villaggio tanto per
darvi un attimo l'entità le case sono
fatte di fango la luce non c'è il frigo
non hanno per conservare nulla per
conservare i cibi non c'è cultura hanno
un dialetto locale si capiscono solo tra
di loro e abbiamo portato un
trasmettitore un'antenna tutti abbiamo
lanciato il primo contenuto e per loro
anche se era un contenuto religioso era
una festa una festa perché sentivano
qualcuno che gli era vicino che li
aiutava questa è la radio che salva la
vita
e quando dico che la radio è un media
che forse probabilmente non deve essere
influenzato al digitale è perché è
un'altra mission costa d'avorio cambio
del governo
la prima cosa che capita quando c'è un
cambio un movimento un cambio politico
un attacco di stato la prima cosa che
fanno bombardano il traliccio radio
perché interrompere le comunicazioni e
poi web sono di telefonia e televisivi
ma la prima cosa che si rifà si ributta
su una radio da campo perché costa poco
e veloce tutti lasciano usare questa è
la radio la radio
cambia il paradigma di un paese
questa è la differenza della radio
arriva dove gli altri mi vien non
arrivano perché non ha solo uno scopo
commerciale e non ha bisogno di un like
non ha bisogno di competenze e
soprattutto non vi prende i vostri dati
la cosa differente è proprio quella che
la radio ti importa una voce ti da un
qualcosa in più perché lì manca la voce
sanno i social anno instagram non
c'hanno facebook non c'è dappertutto il
mondo se noi guardiamo sempre qua a
milano roma new york londra e tutto
facile ma bisogna girare il mondo dalla
papua nuova guinea al vietnam è lì che
bisogna viverlo in media e dove un media
cambia un paese con questa è una
semplice radio abbiamo fatto qualche
milione queste le abbiamo distribuite
oggi con warfare work family questo
progetto abbiamo in oltre 70 paesi oltre
50 lingue dialetti locali che è quella
la difficoltà la difficoltà ad entrare
ad entrare con incontrato la comunità
abbiamo aiutato i profughi dal sud sudan
passare con un campo che era grande
quanto copparo abbiamo usato questa non
instagram o una storia però
forse non abbiamo più bisogno perché
oggi noi dobbiamo regalare il nostro
dati a tutte ho sentito prima
noi se non sappiamo dove siamo se non ci
paghiamo se non diciamo cosa stiamo
facendo noi siamo così però si parla
molto di the box di disintossicazione di
allontanamento di riprendersi la propria
identità
la radio in molti mi chiedono di pensare
come possa essere in futuro la radio sta
cambiando domani io vedo una radio che
nuova una radio con la vostra musica che
la prende la vostra su chi fa e con il
vostro oroscopo con il vostro al podcast
preferito il vostro programma preferito
dello zoo di 105 di odi crociani o il
podcast che preferite ma però non è
vostra e degli altri
e voi la componente ma qua c'è un
problema che vi chiedono qualcosa in
cambio
la vostra identità i vostri gusti le
vostre emozioni quando avete alzato il
volume probabilmente qualche parola
chiave che poi utilizzeranno per
rivenderli qualcosa io le tecnologie ci
supportano sta arrivando il 5 g oramai
non è un problema tecnologico non è un
problema di contenuto è un problema di
sapere se noi vogliamo oggi cedere
l'identità tutto quello che abbiamo noi
lo stiamo regalando la radio ancora mi
lascia libere
e noi in italia siamo il fondatore della
radio
circa 94 anni fa dal 1895 all'inizio
cioè dei miei primi esperimenti il web e
la forte intuizione direi quasi la
visione chiara e sicura che le
trasmissioni radio telegrafiche
sarebbero state possibili attraverso le
più grandi distanze lui marconi a
bologna acceso circa un secolo fa la
radio
aiutatemi a non spegnerla